global marketing and investor relations
with Qualcomm let me read you the
question I'm going to answer what would
you like to be historically remembered
for and that's submitted by Wendy buckle
Minh on facebook Wendy I made a decision
early in my career when working in the
wireline business for a
telecommunications company to go to
wireless because I thought it was more
exciting and the idea that as
communications that could reach more
people because it was easier to deploy
an entire fixed telephone system and it
was one of the best decisions I ever
made and so what I hope to be remembered
for is I've gone to work for a company
Qualcomm who's really promoting the use
of wireless technology globally and
we're doing a lot to help drive down the
cost so that we can make communications
accessory to as many people as possible
the reason we do that as we look and
there's a direct correlation to GP
growth in areas where connectivity has
been enabled so tremendous increase in
GDP with the growth access to the
internet and access to communications
and I think communications is really
changing the world if you look at what
happened the Arab Spring was coordinated
through social media and wireless
networks so I look at our business and
see so many areas where the technology
can be applied whether it's education or
in health care where people don't have
access to health care today will provide
that access through wireless networks
and where they might have access we can
actually do things to help reduce costs
or give people the ability to better
manage their chronic diseases like
diabetes so I think wireless will have a
tremendous impact on the globe it's
already the largest platform that human
history has ever created and that's just
on voice I think the impact of providing
data connectivity and access to
information will even greater so thank
you for your question